music Monday music Monday with
Tom McDonald and Adam Calhoun
song called American flags 6.6 million
views number eight on YouTube trending
music suggested apparently by many creme
de La Creme members and whichever
producer this was misspelled
you're welcome
take it away
[Music]
wow
you're never gonna pretend that I give a
damn anybody who's offended can get it
we throwing hands anybody not trying to
make America great again your Pawn
you're a clown better know where I stand
I'm the white boy with the middle
fingers
I know white boy's gonna hold me down
anywhere dog
I was raised to be brave to the Grave
United States we love the country that
they've been corrupting go welcome go
broker if you ain't awake you're gonna
pause there I like this distinction he's
drawing which is look we love the
country but they've been corrupting it
so it's a distinction between the
country and the people who are presently
representing the country we're saying
those present representatives of the
country are corrupt and not worthy of
our admiration support so that the real
kind of patriotism gets to something
deeper than just these derelicts who are
running the show keep going
[Music]
it's got all the bangers take a look
inside my closet you gonna see way more
than hangers hammers like I do
construction ammo imma shoot at
something why you think we own these
guns so we could just go do some hunting
you must not pay close attention
government they want the vision only
treason
it's only treason if you lose so now
you're starting to get the sense okay
hold on
is this video about is this some kind of
bush era you know go over there bomb the
Middle East that's what conservatism is
that's what American patriotism is who's
going to see American flags where are we
rolling up then you say there's a much
more radical song because he's saying no
no the tanks are for here
the the revolution is for here it's only
treason if you lose which gets to this
point that Al Sharpton accidentally made
on MSNBC said could you imagine if
Thomas Jefferson tried to overthrow the
government it's like I can't imagine
that yeah I think he did he actually
declared independence and there's a
whole document about it you know then
they fought a war and then it was the
Constitution so it raises this
Troublesome part of American History
which is that to be patriotic we need to
support our country and oppose
Revolution but the country was founded
sort of in a revolution so
or the January 6th guys are they great
heroes are they Great American Patriots
or are they terrible evil
insurrectionists who are traitors and
ought to be locked away and throw away
the key well
Tom McDonald's answer here is well it's
treason if you lose
[Music]
so now you see it becomes clearer what
the meaning of the song is because at
first it just seems like it's this
platitude and it's like American flags
guns grits and gravy shooting guns and
being American but no it's much more
radical he's saying we're under attack
well it's not we're under attack from
foreign forces we're not under attack
from Muslim terrorists or something
we're under attack by the people running
the country they who are Banning us they
who cancel us for speaking facts and if
you're man enough come stand with us
we're taking the USA back from that
whose day that is the the corrupt
establishment that's running it so once
again you see this division between the
rulers and the country the irony here
the Paradox I guess is that the flag
that these insurrectionists who are
attacking the government are going to be
waving is the American flag and the
argument for their Revolution is and
this is not stated explicitly but I
think we can infer it is will the ruling
class be waving the American flag
maybe but maybe not maybe the ruling
class will be waving the rainbow flag
maybe the ruling class will be waving
the BLM flag or something I don't I
don't see the ruling liberal
establishment wrapping itself in the
American flag all that often very often
they're attacking it they're spitting it
they're disrespecting it they're not
standing for the Star-Spangled Banner
it's the conservatives who are the ones
who hug the American flag so if a
revolution if an insurrection
waves the standard of the country and
the civil authority of the country
rejects the standard of the country who
are the real Patriots that's the
question he's raising
[Music]
Stars you see Stripes you see flags and
the trucks and the bikes every time we
pull up we go hard we outside we got
flags on our arms that are tatted there
for life every time we pull up we don't
care if you mad we cherish this land the
haters can't get buried in red states
there is the proof of of my intuition
there which is okay this is about
juxtaposing two different kinds of flags
and who's waving which standard and
there he
which is he says they set the flag on
fire
they set fire to Old Glory to Turning
fabric to Ash well we're the ones waving
American flags and and this is not just
a little political campaign we've got to
tat it on our arms for life we got it on
our bikes even even this repetition
every time we pull up you see stars you
see Stripes you see flags on the cars
and the trucks and the bikes
the reason he's going on so specifically
is it's ever we're always doing this all
the time we the conservatives we're the
ones who even in our quiet private lives
going down the street even just tatted
on our arms I mean I'm not a big Tad guy
but a lot of conservatives have these
sorts of things tatted on their arms and
they're they're doing because it's
really part of their identity and so
who's the real representative of the
country who are the real Patriots I have
one big complaint about that song which
is
it was missing a ukulele
maybe a sitar I don't know it's missing
it was missing
some exotic instrument
and an exotic instrumentalist
[Music]
but otherwise uh really uh
really deep stuff to probe here on a
song that's apparently on at the surface
level is just like every other kind of
pro-america song you've ever heard but
there's a lot more going on underneath
the surface
[Music]